en france des migrants sans abris et
leurs soutiens ont installé hier soir
environ 1 250 tentes sur le parvis de
l'hôtel de ville de paris
une action symbolique ils réclament une
solution d'hébergement les associations
eux réclament une prise en charge de ces
sans abri coûté selon les associations
bah ils ont rien à manger ils dorment
sous des ponts à la merci finalement de
tous les dangers dans les rues de paris
et la voilà on est là pour dire que
c'est plus à nous de le faire et qu'il
faut que ces mineurs soient mis à l'abri
et ça fait des mois qu'on demande en
fait qu'on nous vienne en aide et en
fait y'a pas de réponse donc on est
obligé terre des actions comme ça pour
pouvoir finalement mettre des jeunes
dans des dispositifs gouvernementaux
sans que ça soit à nous de le faire ça
sert au moins à ne plus être sous les
ponts et cachés dans des lieux sordides
où on est chacun dans sa misère l'idée
l'idée de ces campements c'est aussi
d'être ensemble et ensemble être plus
fort et c'est ça qu'on essaye de faire
dans ses actions c'est d'arrêter d'être
des invisible caché sous les ponts dans
le xviiie que si les choses étaient
mises en place
on peut imaginer que tout ça
n'existerait pas donc il ya une réelle
volonté aussi de laisser faire ça et de
montrer ça pour dire regardez il y en a
trop et regarder comment on vous
accueille
ne venez pas parce que quoi qu'il arrive
ça sera comme ça en fait donc j'ai une
réelle volonté de l'état de laisser
faire ça imaginez que dans un pays riche
comme la france ce n'est quelques
milliers de personnes par an qui rentre
chez nous on pourrait si on avait la
volonté politique les accueillir